There's going to be laughter and tears You will hear some thoughts of Florentina Stefano Going to be rough and honest, always funny and mostly true.
Welcome to the podcast U.F.O. Welcome to the podcast, not one insider fact fact But there's this person listening closely With lots excitement for this new episode Flowers smile from cheek to cheek This one's for you, and flowers smile in two Welcome to the podcast UFR.
Welcome to the podcast UFR. Hallo ihr Lieben, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO mit Stefan Tietze. Und Flo und Tien Will, hallo, herzlich willkommen, vielen Dank an Christina, dich Christina für dieses fantastische Intro, heute mit Gitarre, Gitarrenbegleitung. Sehr schön, ja, ja. Ich habe lange Gitarre gespielt, ich beherrsche es mittlerweile, glaube ich, kaum noch. Also ich glaube, House of the Rising Sun kriege ich gerade noch hin. Und das, mehr eigentlich nicht. Also ich glaube, ich habe wirklich Jahre meines Lebens verschenkt. Ja, genau, so geht es mir auch. Und dann ist man häufig in so Gitarrengeschäften, nein, ist das für eine Lüge. Man ist in Gitarrengeschäften mal und weil man den Geruch mag. Ich habe es bei Geschäften häufig, dass ich den Geruch mag und deswegen in die Läden gehe. Aber bei Gitarrengeschäften ist es dann immer schön, dass an den Wänden immer so Zettel hängen wie auf gar keinen Fall Stairway to Heaven spielen, danke. Ja, ich glaube, du hast es. Es gibt drei hier, die alle können und die spielen dann gespielt, genau wie in der Piano-Sektion wahrscheinlich steht, mit auf gar keinen Fall Amelie spielen, weil sonst rasten hier alle aus. Ich glaube, das ist die grösste Ehre für einen Musiker, in so einem Gitarrenladen zu hängen als bitte nicht das spielen, wir können es nicht mehr hören. Wenn ihr Paradise von Florentin Will spielt, dann raste ich aus. Und ich komme so vorbei und so yes, yes, yes, yes. Man ist ein anderer für ein Team, Pot Twist. Naja, ich hatte immer ein bisschen Mitleid mit meinem Gitarrenlehrer, weil ich mir dachte, der ist studierter Musiker und hängt jeden Tag mit den gröbsten Amateuren ab, die es in der Musikszene gibt. Ein paar Highlights aus meiner Musikerkarriere, man hat ja Gruppenunterricht und dann hatte ich mit einem. Hatte ich nicht, hatte ich irgendwann dann auch lange Zeit Einzelunterricht. Ich hatte immer Gruppenunterricht, ich hatte gegen Ende dann Einzelunterricht, aber Gruppenunterricht und irgendwann hat jemand so, da ist irgendwas in meiner Gitarre drin, weil da ist so ein Loch drin und dann fallen Sachen rein. Bleck drin. Da ist irgendwas drin, guckt so und macht die Gitarre so über sich. Zehnminütiges Schütteln über den Kopf, überkopfiges Schütteln. Musiker nicken jetzt wissend in der U-Bahn, ja, kenne ich, schüttelt das, was auch immer da drin ist, raus, schüttelt es raus, was war's? Ein Stück Schokolade. Ah, hat das dann gegessen? Das würde mich interessieren. Hat das einfach gegessen, kommentarlos, Schugette. Genau, eine Schugette. Und wo man wirklich als studierter Musiker da sitzt und sich einfach denkt, das ist mein Leben. Ich schaue dem Elfjährigen dabei zu, wie ein Stück Schokolade aus seiner Gitarre ausschnitten wird. Was immer auslässt dabei als studierter Musiker mit den längsten Fingernägeln der Welt an der rechten Hand, sitzt man dann da und denkt, das ist aus meinem Leben geworden und kratzt sich so mit dem Bart, aber die Hand ist einen Meter von dem Gesicht entfernt. weil man das ist auch wirklich da muss man einfach auch den das die da ist die Gitarre einfach das falsche Instrument. Ich finde Instrumente oder generell, nee, ich würde sogar sagen, Sportarten, die deine Anatomie verändern oder Musiker, Musikinstrumente, die deine Anatomie verändern müssen, um es professionell ausüben zu können. Dinge, die deine Anatomie verändern, um es professionell ausführen zu können, sind nicht richtig. Ich habe es total genossen, lange Fingernägel zu haben. Ich fand es immer super. Weil du so faul warst, weil du so fauler Drecksack warst. Nee, dieses Klassische, du kriegst irgendwie schön die Herr der Ringe DVD-Box, Limited Edition, eingeschweißt. Und dann erst mal suchen, gucken, oh, was habe ich? Nee, langer Fingernagel, schön aufstechen. War immer perfekt. Aufstechen? Hattest du auch so kleine dann, also Schoner, die du noch nie drüber gemacht hast, damit es nicht stumpf wird, so Hütchen? Mit so kleinen Schnüren, so kleine Fingerschuhe, die ich meinen Fingern dann angezogen habe und so zugeschnürt habe, mit so kleinen Schnürsenkeln. Aber jetzt nicht stumpf werden. Ja, hatte ich immer. Scharfe Waffen. Ja, man hat ja, man hat ja nur die vier, die vier grössten Finger der rechten Hand, hat man lange Fingernägel, des kleinen Fingers nicht. Und da hatte ich dann immer vier kleine Schuhe drauf, wie so ein kleiner Hund, ein kleiner Welpenhund. Die kleinste Größe von Welpenschuhen passt tatsächlich genau auf deine Finger. Ja, auf deine Fingernägel. Und links raspelkurs. Ja, wahnsinnig kurz, aber Hornhautig von oben bis unten, fand ich toll. Ja, meine, ich hatte auch mit einem Mädchen und die hatte immer das Problem, wie sagt man es, dass sie beim Gitarrespielen sich so konzentriert hat, dass ihr Gesichtsausdruck abgedriftet ist. In Sphären, in denen man sich nicht mal vorstellen will zu sein.
Wo man als Lehrer dann wahrscheinlich denkt, toll, dass
sie sich so konzentriert, das ist ja nicht egal,
aber es ruiniert jede Performance, muss man
ganz ehrlich sagen. Also zur Musik gehört ja schon von
Anfang an immer auch die Performance. Also ist ja
klar, wenn du gut
singen kannst, wirst du kein Popstar, du musst
halt auch deliveren können. Und wenn du
halt den perfekten Ton triffst, aber
dabei irgendwie aussiehst wie so ein Grottenolm, hilft das halt auch nicht weiter. Oh, hallo, ein Schimpfwort aus dem Mittelalter. Hallo, ich grüsse Sie, der feine Herr. Und ich fand es auch toll, es gab eine Szene, wo mein Gitarrenlehrer versucht hat, ihr das mitzuteilen. Aber er hat versucht, und wir im Raum wussten 100 Prozent, was Sache ist. 100 Prozent.
Aber jemand war wahrscheinlich so, hä, was, was meine ich?
Er meinte dann so, ja, das kann man eigentlich nicht gut sagen. Ja, du hast jetzt so schön gespielt, es wäre doch auch toll, wenn dein Gesicht dabei auch so schön aussehen würde. Im Grunde hat er ihr einfach gesagt, du bist hässlich. Du bist grottenhässlich, wenn du spielst. Deswegen habe ich hier diese Papiertüte. Du bist zu hässlich für die klassische Konzertgitarre. Also wir reden nicht von Popstars, sondern für die klassische Konzertgitarre. Und sie hat es nicht gut aufgenommen. Echt nicht? Nein, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr genau, das ist wirklich schon 20 Jahre her. Aber ich glaube, sie hat danach versucht, an sich zu arbeiten. Aber sie hat nie wieder so schön gespielt wie damals. Es ist eigentlich eine schöne Geschichte, dass sie sozusagen dadurch ihr musikalisches Talent verloren hat, dass sie sich in die Konvention der Gesellschaft zwingen musste. Sieht aber blendend aus jetzt. Aber mittelmässiger Gitarristin leider nur. Traurig, dass man schon sagen kann, das ist 20 Jahre her und es macht Sinn, oder? Es kann gar nicht sein. Weil das sagt man so, das ist auch schon 20 Jahre her, das ist auch schon ewig her, Synonym. Und das ist gruselig, weil mittlerweile macht das ja sogar Sinn. Also ich habe ja vor 20 Jahren schon, war ich ja schon ein Mensch, da wie er schon existiert als Mann. Das fand ich so toll an 2000, so dass du immer gut rechnen konntest. Du wusstest so, oh der Zweite Weltkrieg, mein Gott, das ist auch schon 55 Jahre her. Aber so 2020 ist noch ganz geil, aber dann wenn es in die 23er, 27er geht. Ja, also da fängt doch jetzt nicht mit der Nazi-Nummer, das ist doch jetzt auch schon, ja kommt darauf an, wenn man 75 Jahre geht, man verliert einfach so ein bisschen den Dampf. Man verliert Emotionen, vielleicht ganz gut. Ja, kommt, stimmt. In diesen stürmischen Zeiten vielleicht ganz gut auch mal die Emotionen zu verlieren, über so blöde Rechenvalentitäten. Ist das ein guter Tipp für Choleriker, wenn man sich aufregt, einfach kurz Kopf rechnen? Kurz Kopf rechnen. Einfach 180 durch 16? Einfach kurz, du bist kurz abgelenkt und du kannst, niemand kann wütend rechnen. Du kannst nicht sagen, fuck hier, minus drei, drei im Sinn, ziehst es runter durch zwei, geht nicht. Du kannst nur kümmern rechnen. Rätseln allgemein kann man nicht wirklich fies. Du hast noch nie eine wütende Person Kreuzworträtsel machen sehen. Du hast noch nie so wirklich, dass er mit Wut den Kugelschreiber zu tief ins Papier drückt. Hast du noch nie gesehen bei den Kreuzworträtseln? Hat man nicht. Warum rätseln hat man das nicht? Man rätselt gerne rum. Knobeln, knifeln. Immer dieses Verschmitzte oben links in die Ecke gucken. Als wären da die Antworten. Ja, ja. Sind sie meistens nicht. Die sind meistens oben rechts. Meistens. Aber da guckt die meist nicht. Machst du gerne Kreuzworträtseln? Ich gar nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Ich hatte eine kurze Sudoku-Phase, war mir zu schwer. Ja, wo er ehrlich gesagt hat. Man gibt verschiedene, das finde ich auch sehr interessant, das Firmenmagazin meiner Mutter. Meine Mutter ist Personalerin und die betreut dann immer auch die Firmenmagazine, die bei ihr in der Firma rausgegeben werden. Das ist eine relativ große Firma und so, die haben auch schon ein paar Mitarbeiter. Und dann geben die jeden Monat so ein Magazin heraus. Und die Abteilung meiner Mutter muss auch immer so ein Gewinnspiel dann machen, sich ausdenken. Und dann haben sie jetzt neulich auch mal ein Sudoku darin gehabt. Meine erste Frage war, wie habt ihr das denn gemacht? Habt ihr euch das ausgedacht? Weil es gibt ja sehr, sehr schwierige Sudokus und sehr, sehr einfache. Die aber immer noch lösbar sind. Ja genau, aber wo Ja genau, aber woher muss du nicht in Mathematik genius sein, um zumindest erst mal zu wissen, ist das überhaupt lösbar, zweitens zu wissen, wenn ja, wie schwierig ist das denn zu lösen und dann gab es halt Karten für Borussia Dortmund, wo ich denke, das ist auch kein trivialer Preis, so wenn es niemand bekommen kann, geil, also großen Respekt, dass ihr, habt ihr die Karten überhaupt und habt ihr das lösbar gestaltet?
Fand ich ganz toll.
Rita, ihr habt die Karten verloren, mach so Doku nochmal schwerer.
Bring it up a notch.
Nimm die Fünfen raus.
Mach es mal so 12% komplizierter und dann rumrechnen, Integrale werden gezückt, Firminternes Memo, nimm die Filmen raus, Rita. Ist mir ein Rätsel, wie man das machen kann. Ja, ich glaube, ist schwierig. Vielleicht hat sie einfach den leichten Weg genommen und einfach abgeschrieben. Schön Bahnhofskiosk, irgendwie abfotografiert, die ganz, die Ultraschweren, die mit dem Sumoringer vorne drauf, abfotografiert, abgeschrieben. Ich will jetzt seiner Mutter gar nichts vorwerfen. Nö, klingt aber ein bisschen so. Naja. Aber ehrlich gesagt, dann neulich musste sie die vier Abteilungen Tassen rausbringen, war dann die Idee, weil es schon lange keinen Unfall mehr gab an Maschinen und so weiter. Und dann habe ich gefragt, ach krass, wie lange war der denn ohne Unfall? Und dann waren es 300 Tage, wo ich aber auch sagen muss, das ist nicht so lang. Und sie hat dann gesagt, ja stimmt auch nicht, da ist bestimmt nicht was passiert, aber das muss man ja nicht an die große Glocke hängen. Und eigentlich ist es deutlich weniger, schlägt so ein Kreuz. Gott habe ich es nicht an die große Glocke hängen, schweige Minute, folgte darauf. Aber ehrlich gesagt, also 300 Tage ist es nicht so viel, oder? Für die Firma? Und dann habe ich mir sagen lassen, es wäre relativ viel. Die Frage, was mit Unfall gemeint ist, aber ich war überrascht, weil ich habe letztens eine, ich liebe ja diese Fabrik-Dokus, wie wird XY hergestellt. Oh, da musst du unbedingt American Factory gucken. Oh ja, habe ich geschaut, habe ich geschaut. Ganz toll. Aber das meine ich gar nicht. Aber können wir gleich, erinnere mich dran, lass uns gleich was drüber sprechen. Ja, ja, ja. Ich meine so etwas wie, wie wird Zwieback hergestellt, weil man denkt sich, ja, wie wird denn Zwieback hergestellt? Also es ist immer eine Frage, die man nicht beantworten kann. Mit Öfen und Brot. Ne, aber was heißt Zwieback? Heißt, dass es zweimal gebacken wird. Zwieback, zweimal backen, easy. Zwieback. Schau mal, habt ihr schon was mitgenommen? Und da habe ich eine Doku gesehen über Schokoküsse, grandios, grandios. Schoko und Küsse. Und da habe ich was gesehen. Und es ist immer so dieser magische Moment, wenn man in der Realität Dinge sieht, die man eigentlich nur aus Fiktion kennt. Und da in dieser Schokokussfabrik hing tatsächlich so ein Schild, kein Unfall seit und dann so weggewischt und dann so zwei, zwanzig Tage. Und ich dachte, sowas gibt es nur bei den Simpsons. Wenn der radioaktive Raptor irgendwie durchs Kontrollzentrum stampft und dann Homer so gelangweilt null Tage hinschreibt oder so, als Gag. Nee, ist ja auch wichtig, das ist ja kein Gag. Weil das habe ich mich nämlich immer gefragt, weil ich finde es immer gut, wenn man Dokoku schaut mit einer Frage, weil wenn man sagt, so guckt, ja Formel 1, guckt man sich so an, ich finde es immer gut, man muss eine Doku angucken und dann wirklich nehmt euch mal die Zeit und ihr könnt eure Dokumentationsseh-Genuss erhöhen, indem ihr so eine Doku, ihr lest den Titel, irgendwie Mönche in Tibet und dann denkt ihr euch, okay, was ist meine Frage an diese Doku?
Was sind denn Mönche in Tibet?
Gut, vielleicht, nee, nee, sowas meine ich gar nicht, überhaupt nicht, sondern eher was Spezielles, was Konkretes, sowas, warum sind die eigentlich orange angezogen? Dürfen Mönche in Tibet denn Sex haben? So, die Frage. Und ich hatte die Frage an diese Schokokus-Dokumentationen, ist es Absicht, dass die Dickmanns ganz oben an der Spitze eine kreisrunde Stelle haben, wo es minimal dickere Schokolade ist?
Ja, weil da der Punkt ist, an dem das abgenommen wird, der Strahl.
Richtige Antwort, Stefan Tietze, 100 Punkte.
Bisschen sperrig ausgedrückt, aber ich glaube, im Kern ist es das.
Weil, wenn du in so einen Dickmann reinweist.
Meine Frage wäre gewesen übrigens, was kommt zuerst dran oder rein?
Die Schokolade außenrum oder der Schaum innen drin?
Ja, denk mal nach.
Schaum innen drin.
Und ich dachte nämlich.
Das muss ja keine schwere Frage sein.
Ich kann die Antwort ja schon wissen.
Anfängerfrage, ja.
Da ist doch nur so ein kleines Lämmchen vorne auf dem Cover drauf.
Und ich dachte nämlich immer, es ist Absicht, weil wenn du in so einen Dickmann reinbeißt, muss der der erste bisschen so richtig knacken. Und ich dachte, ich mache die absichtlich oben so ein bisschen dickere Schokolade. Wobei ist denn jemand rein? Du hast ja... Klar. Aber die Zähne berühren die dicke Stelle nicht, weißt du? Doch klar, du... Du brauchst so rein. Auch spannend, dass deine Hand ihn nicht bewegt, aber dein Kopf die Bewegung macht. Du kannst deine Hand zum Kopf. Wie der Hahn von einer Pistole, der so aufschlägt. Oder ein Huhn, was so auf die Körper einpickt. Genau, das ist eine klassische Pickbewegung. Der Mensch stammt ja vom Dinosaurier ab und Dinosaurier stammen von Hühnern ab. Und deswegen hat man diese Pickbewegung noch drin. Aber die konnte mir beantwortet werden, die Frage, denn du hast völlig recht, diese Spritzschnute, die das so aufschäumt, lässt oben nochmal so einen kleinen Dupser drin und dann, wenn das übergossen wird, dann ist da ein bisschen dicker drin. Achtet mal drauf, ist wirklich so. Spannend. Lass mich ganz kurz noch Schokokuss abschliessen. Kleiner Tipp an die Freaks da draußen, die sich jetzt vielleicht eine Box holen. Versucht mal, diese kreisrunde Stelle oben abzuknibbeln, die rauszunehmen und dann den Schokokus auszusaugen. So mit den Lippen oben drauf und dann einmal komplett auszusaugen, ohne dass die Hülle bricht. Naja, gut, das ist die Challenge für euch. Ist noch nicht passiert. Das ist die Challenge für euch. Es gibt drei Maschinenbahnen mit jeweils weisser Vollmilch und Zartbitterschokolade oder es ist eine Maschine, die dreimal gefüllt wird, links, rechts, Mitte oder die erste Variante, dass es einfach drei Bahnen sind. ich glaube nicht ich glaube es ist die erste variante die variante wo man wo es dann drei
einer maschine sind weil es diese maschine sind auch immer sehr teuer. Hat man die einfach dann einmal gebaut in dem Land so und dann? Das denke ich mir auch immer so, ob es Fabriken für Fabriken gibt. Ja klar, klar. Auf jeden Fall Maschinenbaufirmen gibt es. Und womit bauen die ihre Maschinen? Die Tüfteln, die bauen ja einmal. Jetzt hast du nicht mit dem Verb Tüfteln rausgeflüchtet. Aber ein beliebtes Flüchtverb. Aber ehrlich gesagt, die... Klassisches Fluchtverb, ja. Aber die haben, nee, die bauen die ja nur einmal. Bestehst du, Maschinen, die Idee von Maschinen ist ja, die Redundanz, also etwas wiederherstellen zu können. Diese Maschine existiert ja oft aber nur einmal. Das heißt, die wird einmal gebaut, deswegen brauchst du keine Maschine für die Maschine, du brauchst Menschen, die die Maschine bauen. Da kann ich übrigens, ja, ich könnte Ihnen empfehlen, wenn mir der Name einfiele. Reeves ist der Nachname. Es ist ein total toller YouTuber. Nein, nein, nein, nein, da wird es nicht gegoogelt. Reeves. R-E-E-V-E-S. Das reicht. Der Vorname entfällt mir gerade. Das reicht. John Reeves. Und der macht ganz tolle Videos auf YouTube, wie er Maschinen baut, umbaut. Das sind ja ganz tolle Ideen. Unter anderem hat er auch so Computerprogramme nachgebaut und hat so ein Computerprogramm geschrieben, wo Leute ihm bei Twitter, weil er ist umgezogen, hat eine ganz leere Wohnung und er wollte, dass Leute ihm bei Twitter etwas schreiben können, ein Inventar, ein Möbelstück, was auch immer, etwas, was in sein Zimmer gestellt werden soll. Und dann hat ein Algorithmus geschrieben, der gemerkt hat, welche Tweets am beliebtesten waren und die dann automatisch bei Amazon gekauft hat, diese Dinge. Ganz tolle Idee. Und dann hat er das angestellt, es lief genau für, ich glaube, fünf Minuten oder vielleicht auch eine Stunde, und er hat automatisch abgestellt. Und in der Zeit wurden, keine Ahnung, 400 Pakete bei Amazon, 400 Gegenstände bestellt. Und die wurden dann geliefert. Alles daran ist toll. Auch der Moment, wo der Paketbot einfach wirklich einfach auch sauer war, weil er halt sehr viele, 400 Pakete dahinstellen musste. Ja klar, davon 380 Dildos. Ich meine, das natürlich, hast du viel zu tragen. Eben nicht, es gab, glaube ich, keine doppelten Sachen,
aber sehr viel Quatsch auf jeden Fall.
Ganz tolles Video. Und der hat auch
zum Beispiel einen Roboter gebaut, einen
Staubsauger-Roboter, der immer schreit,
wenn er irgendwo gegenfährt.
Und flucht. Was eine ganz tolle
Idee ist. Ah, das ist eine gute Idee. Weil natürlich,
wenn ich meinen Staubsauger-Roboter habe, den ich auch nicht mehr benutze, um echt zu sein.
Weil es ist viel einfacher, selber zu saugen,
machen wir uns nichts vor.
Der fährt dann andauernd ja irgendwo gegen,
und es ist ein großes Hände beim Kopf zusammenschlagen,
und die wenn ich meinen Staubsaugerroboter habe, den ich auch nicht mehr benutze, um echt zu sein, weil es ist viel einfacher selber zu saugen, machen wir uns nichts vor, der fällt dann andauernd ja irgendwo gegen und es ist ein großes Hände im Kopf zusammenschlagen und dem hinterherlaufen und sagen, das gibt's jetzt alles, das glaube ich jetzt nicht, das kann jetzt nicht der Wahrheit entsprechen. Und man schimpft die aus. So, guck, wo du dich jetzt hin manövriert hast. Guck, wo du dich hin manövriert hast. Wie kommst du da wieder raus? Ja, gar nicht, kann ich dir sagen. Piep, piep, muss ich jetzt da rausholen oder was? Ja piep, Akku wechseln, ja und jetzt, mehr hast du nichts zu sagen. Alles klar, und mein alter Staubsauger nickt so zufrieden in der Ecke. Und der fährt ja immer gegen Wenders, ist ja die Idee und dann ändert er die Richtung und der hat dann einfach eingebaut, hat einen Laubelschortsprecher eingebaut und der schreit immer, wenn er irgendwo gegenfährt. Fuck! Goddammit! Sehr lustig auf jeden Fall. Tolle Idee. Und der baut Maschinen. Aber es rüchst in der Frage, natürlich werden auch in Firmen Maschinen gebaut, dann werden die einmal gebaut und irgendwo hingebracht. Finde ich übrigens einen Mega-Job. Also wenn eine Firma zu dir kommt und sagt, wir brauchen hier und hierfür, wir brauchen Schokoküsse, also was soll das denn sein? Ja, so Schaumstoff und drüber so eine Schokoglasur und darunter eine Waffel. Wir würden das gerne in Serie geben. Hier ist ein Prototyp und dann kriegst du so einen schrumpeligen, ganz seltsamen aussehenden Prototypen in die Hand. Dann musst du, bist du mit der Aufgabe betraut, wie du das jetzt auch dann durch den Hygienemastäben angemessen in Serie produzieren kannst. Voll geil. Und da musst du so eine Maschine bauen. Ich glaube, das wäre für uns total toll.
Als Kind hatte ich lange den Traum, einen eigenen Softdrink zu erfinden. Also so the next Cola war immer so mein Ding. So habe ich es gepitcht, ohne es zu haben. Aber so habe ich es meinen Eltern immer gepitcht. Das ist halt so die nächste Cola. Was, was sieht wohin? Das entsteht gerade noch, aber das ist halt so, wenn man sagt so, ah, was kann ich denn,
man kann so, immer wenn man ein nicht-alkoholisches Getränk sucht, nimmt man eine Cola und das, was ich mache, wird halt so die nächste Cola. Okay. Halt so, das wird halt den verdrängen. Was ist da drin dann? So, dass wenn du halt sagst Mac-Menü und dann fragt die Bedienung so mit Cola, so oder sie fragt nicht mit Apfelscholle, sondern nee, die fragt halt mit Cola.
Also es ist so das Go-to-süsse Getränk halt.
Ja, und ich glaube, das wird sehr erfolgreich.
Aber geil, gab es da Versuche dazu?
Da gab es mehrfach Versuche.
Ich habe ja auch versucht, eine Soße zu entwickeln, da habe ich heute noch das Rezept.
Und man merkt so ein bisschen, wie der siebenjährige Florentin auf dieses Rezept gekommen ist, denn es lautet ungefähr so ein bisschen Ketchup, ein bisschen Senf, ein bisschen Tomi Barbecue Soße, ein bisschen Cocktail Soße und man denkt, kann es sein, dass du von allem, was in der Küche war, einfach ein bisschen genommen hast und am Ende ja ja, schmeckt ganz gut. Schmeckt okay. Aber kann man nicht rekreieren. Übrigens, interessante Frage, gibt's in einem Produkt, was wir kennen, Lebensmittel, weil du sagst gerade Tomy-Barbecue-Sosse, gibt es vielleicht, gibt es in Lebensmitteln, die man kaufen kann, irgendwo eine Zutat, die man auch kaufen kann? Ja, ja, ja. Steht im Rewe etwas mit meinetwegen Tomy-Senf oder sowas als Zutat, die man auch kaufen kann, steht im Rewe etwas mit meinetwegen Tomi-Senf oder sowas als Zutat da drin? Bestimmt, oder? Ich habe mich auch schon mal gefragt, ob man das darf. Also darf ich Fanta und Cola kaufen, die mischen und als Florentins-Supergetränk verkaufen? Oder sagt da jemand, nee, das geht nicht, das ist doch lame. Ich glaube, das wird nie funktionieren, weil es ja in der Definition schon mal teuer ist. Es ist halt sehr teuer machen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es erlaubt ist. Das ist genau doppelt so teuer wie Fanta und Cola. Warum? Ja, aber du meinst, es gibt irgendwo so süße Popcorn und dann steht so drin, halt irgendwie so Lorenz Popcorn plus Zucker. Diamant, Zucker. Lorenz so verdammt nochmal. Gute Idee. Salz und Lorenz Popcorn. Oder Salzstangen, Lorenz Salzstangen, Salz abgeknibbelt. Und dann verkauft man als salzlose Salzstangen. Genau. Als Stangen. Ja, oder diese Fledermäuse von Haribo, nur halt ohne die Flügel. Abgebissen.
Aber das finde ich nicht so interessant, weil Senf ist ja schon auch mal eine Zutat, die häufig auch in Gerichten, auch so Fertiggerichten und so drin ist.
Auch in Soßen ist es mit Senf einfach drin.
Welcher Senf?
Ja genau, welcher Senf? Deren Senf? Nee, die werden ja gekauft, den billigsten Senf gekauft. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, also ich denke mir darüber, Entschuldigung, ganz doll husten an Fall gerade. Es ist zumindest nie was draus geworden aus meinem Getränk gewünscht, aber ich habe ein neues Topgetränk entdeckt, und zwar für Sommer, Sommer 2020, wer noch Lust hat auf ein Topgetränk, habe ich jetzt ein paar Mal genossen. Wie, wer noch Lust hat, der Sommer hat nicht mal angefangen. Na eben, deswegen, du musst ja früh dein Sommergetränk festlegen, sonst denken die Leute, oh okay, es ist schon Mai und er hat immer noch kein Sommergetränk. Respekt, respekt. Deswegen versuche dieses Jahr, früh dran zu sein. Ich empfehle euch den Arnold Palmer. Und das ist zwei Teile Eistee, ein Teil Limonade. Sehr einfach. Nee, aber Arnold Palmer ist doch alkoholisches Getränk. Nee, es gibt auch eine alkoholische Variante, aber der klassische Arnold Palmer ist zwei Teile Eistee, ein Teil Zitwe. Und wer war Arnold Palmer? Golfer und ganz, ganz tolles Getränk. Schaut es euch mal an, es ist toll, weil dieses Herbe vom Eistee mit diesem Süssen vom Eistee und dem Fruchtigen vom Eistee, das passt super gut zusammen einfach.
Hat der das erfunden, Arnold Palmer?
Der hat das erfunden, der hat das immer wieder bestellt und irgendwann hat eine andere Kundin in derselben Bar auch mal gesagt, I want to have that Palmer Drink und so hat sich das dann weiterentwickelt. Ihm selber war das aber immer unangenehm. Roche Calperinia liegt heute noch von dem Namen. Er selber hat anscheinend nie einen Arnold Palmer bestellt, sondern immer gesagt, zwei Teile Eistee, ein Teil Limonade und dann der Barkeeper, also einen Arnold Palmer. Ooooooh! Da wusste nicht, dass er ihm gegenüber sitzt. Nein. Ach, toll, toll. Der wäre ich gerne gewesen, genau so einer, der sagt so, ich hätte gerne ein Mac-Menü mit Burger, mit Big Mac und Barbecue-Soße und noch eine Schmipp dazu. Und ich so, ich weiß nicht, dass ich der Erfinder von Schmipp bin, dass ich damals als Siebenjähriger diese Kirschschorle entdeckt habe. Zwei Teile Cola, ein Teil Fanta und die sagt, ah, ein Schmipp. Ja, genial. Manchmal ist zwei eins die bessere Mischfälle. Das denke ich wahrscheinlich Familie Metzomix heute noch. Ja, und jetzt hat man halt ... L Mix heute noch. Ja. Und jetzt habe ich halt zu Hause bei mir das grosse Hotdog-Problem, wo man immer acht Brötchen mit sechs Würstchen hat. Und ich habe jetzt immer das Problem, dass ich immer das nicht auf null kriege. Wenn man es immer zwei zu eins mischt, kriegst du es immer nicht auf null. Genau. Ich nenne es Kuba-Liebe-Problem, weil du immer nachfüllst. Was ist eigentlich aus dem, da ist Stefan von 2009 geworden. Ach, was ist denn aus dem geworden? Das muss man aber hinter sich lassen. Nee, aber das habe ich damals im Podcast schon Kuba-Libo-Problem genannt, weil man immer nicht die Mischung genau hinbekommt und dann wird es einfach mehr. Weil dann füllst du, dann ist zu viel Rum drin, dann machst du einen Cola nach, dann ist es Cola-Laldi, dann machst du mehr Rum nach und irgendwann hast du einfach mehr, mehr von dem Getränk. Und das ist genau bei dem Ding auch so. Da ist jetzt mittlerweile sehr viel so ein Anapama-Tank bei mir stehen, Badewanne ist voller Anapama. Das Glas ist gar nicht gross genug. Die Badewanne ist leider voller Salz immer noch, das heißt, da kann ich mich umschichten. Ah ja, das ist die alte Geschichte. Ich habe damals auch einen Drink kreieren wollen, ich bin eher in die herbere Richtung gegangen, ich habe ein Gewürz, ich habe primär einfach nur Gewürze, ein ganz tolles Gewürzregal und da habe ich dann immer Wasser und dann sehr viele Gewürze reingemacht, immer andere und dann immer durch eine Milch mit einem Löffel und dann immer andere Gewürze, einfach nur Gewürze in Wasser und es war immer widerlich. Das löst sich auch nicht auf, oder? Du hast eine verobene Schicht Gewürzschirr. Naja, also solange du rührst, so sieht es einigermaßen aus wie eine kohärente Masse. Sobald du aber das eine, zehn Sekunden stehen lässt, dann setzt sich das ganze Gewürz ab oder bleibt oben, je nach Gewürz. Also da habe ich mir, glaube ich, auch viel Erfahrung. Aber die meisten Sachen sacken so ab. Oregano, vergiss es, fließt einfach irgendwann runter und so. Und ich war ein bisschen ein dusseliges Kind, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Und da habe ich halt immer diese Gewürztrungs versucht an den Mann zu bringen, nicht gut. Ey, vor allem, du sagst ja immer, ein Curry gewinnt. Du sagst ja immer, oh, es ist so schwer, eine Serie zu schreiben, Fernsehen zu produzieren, ist so anstrengend und so schwierig und ich erinnere mich gerade, wo du sagst, schwimmt's oder nicht, es gab ja diese Wissenschaftssendung mal auf MTV, Brainiac, glaube ich, hieß die und ein Segment dieser gesamten Show war Will It Float? Schwimmt's. Schwimmt's. Aber auf Deutsch ist es auch cooler. Ja, eigentlich schon. Schwimmt's. Und dann hieß es so, Weintraube. Und dann so, schwimmt's oder nicht? Und man war so ein Typ, der reinwirft. Genau, dann hast du einfach so, blub, und dann schwimmt's halt oder nicht. Nein. Weintrauben schwimmen, aber es ist eine spannende Frage, weil man fragt sich wirklich, schwimmt es oder nicht? Und wo ich mir auch damals dachte, genial, aber heute rückblickend denke ich mir, die freuen sich, wir lachen ins Feuchtchen, wo die Stunden um Stunden, die fahren einmal an so einen Pool und haben halt irgendwie einen ganzen VW-Bus voller Sachen, werfen alles rein und haben 30 Staffeln schon vorproduziert. Ja, brillant. Schwimmt's. Holz schwimmt ja immer wieder beeindruckend. Ja. Wo ich glaube, das ist uns nochmal für irgendwas ... Das wirkt wie so eine Waffe, die man im ersten Akt angekündigt hat. Genau. Die nochmal wichtig wird. Ja, da kommt noch was Großes. Wurde auch schon ein paar Mal wichtig. Ich erinnere an die Arche Noah. Ja, aber hätte man da nicht mehr draus holen können?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Also vor allem, ja.
Ich sag mal so, das fühlt sich so an, als ob das irgendwann wichtig wird.
Und jetzt gerade mit Überschwemmungen und Viren, die um sich schlagen.
Das ist so ein, irgendwann, also ich hab da mein Holz.
Ich klammer mich an Holz und werde überleben.
Du klammerst dich an dünnen Ast im reissenden Strom der Neuzeit. der Welt. Das kann man metaphorisch, kann man das genau so sagen. Finde ich toll. Werbung. Ganz ehrlich, ich liebe mein good old Taxi. Schön von A nach B kommen und gerade wenn du mal keine Zeit hast, kommst du einfach am Ziel an. Ja, aber dann soll ich jetzt irgendeinen Taxi-Anruf-Service irgendwo durchklingeln. Nein, das gibt es natürlich auch als App, wie bei alles mittlerweile gibt es ja als App. My Taxi war es immer, mittlerweile heißt es Free Now. Und das Coole ist, mittlerweile kannst du sogar ein bisschen günstiger auch einfach einen Fahrer zu dir bestellen. Das ist halt kein Taxi, das heißt Ride, der Service, ist ein bisschen billiger und du kommst trotzdem genauso gut ans Ziel mit lizenzierten Fahrern. Und du weisst vorher, wie viel es kostet die Fahrt.
Ride gibt es bereits in einigen Großstädten Deutschlands, Hamburg, Berlin, Köln, Düsseldorf,
München und Frankfurt.
Und für alle, die Freenow noch nicht nutzen, für die haben wir ein ganz kleines Schmankerl
im Angebot.
Denn ihr könnt den Voucher-Code Ufo7 benutzen, Ufo und die Zahl 7, und dann kriegt ihr 7
Euro Rabatt.
Viel Spaß, gute Fahrt.
Bis dann, viel Spaß beim Podcast.
Werbung. Ich glaube, ich bin ein schlechter Autofahrer. Das habe ich heute gemerkt. Ist mir schon länger klar. Vor allem, wirklich? Du hast ein paar Sachen erzählt. Und man fährt auch nicht so gern mit dir. Wieso das denn? Naja, weil man kennt dich ja und man weiss, du bist ein verschluderter Typ. Also du hast... Jetzt bin ich ein verschluderter Typ. Ja, aber du bist... Also der Stefan von 2008 hat mir dann doch ein bisschen besser gefallen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Nee, du hast dann auch viele Gedanken in deinem Köpfchen und so. Und also du... Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass du dich gerne... Du weißt mich für ein Vollidiot, du kannst es ruhig sagen. Du musst jetzt da nicht groß drum herum reden. Nee, ich, auch sehr clevere Menschen fahren nicht gut Auto. Ich traue dir nicht zu, dass du dich dann darauf konzentrierst und alles andere erstmal so abschalten kannst. Das nehme ich mal als die Beleidigung hin, die sie ist und ordne das mal so ein. Aber auch so, wie du mit Banalitäten des Alltags nicht umgehen kannst und willst, glaube ich, auch akzeptierst du dann einfach,
dann sagst du ja, das Prinzip Ampeln ist doch überholt. Dann stellst du solche Thesen dann auf und dann rast du über Rot oder über die Gegenfahrbahn, weil es dann irgendwie doch der kürzere Weg ist und so. Deswegen glaube ich dir das nicht, dass du die Regeln des Verkehrs akzeptierst. Ja, ich habe letztens im Moment erlebt, und das ist ja das Problem, so also ganz unten, also was sind die vorschlechtesten Menschen? Das sind die, die wissen, dass sie schlecht sind. So, aber dann die allerschlechtesten sind die, die noch nicht mal wissen, dass sie schlecht sind, die so wenig Ahnung haben, dass sie das noch nicht mal wissen. Und ich glaube, ich bin so jemand, weil letztens ist bei mir jemand vorbeigefahren. Ich fahre so vor mich hin, denke mir, ja, alles in Ordnung, drei Räder, äh, vier Räder, Entschuldigung, vier Räder, Anschnall, Angurt, angegurtet, zieht da jemand an mir vorbei und gibt mir den Wischer. Halt so mit der, mit der, mit der gespreizten Hand vor der. Ja, der, sag mal, dir hat mal wo jemand ins Müsli gehustet und gibt mir den. Und ich wusste nicht, warum. Und oft, manchmal ist der so, und man denkt sich, oh fuck, den habe ich jetzt geschnitten, scheiße, und dann kriegst du halt was zurück irgendwie. Ja, also ich sag mal, du kannst mir viel wegbeweisen. Den Finger darf ich ja nicht mehr nennen, laut namibischem Hoheitsgesetz. Ja, sorry. Aber den Wischer, glaube ich, der geht noch. Der geht noch. Und ich wusste nicht, wofür. Ja, das ist immer problematisch. Das ist total problematisch. Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, meine Herren, das ist ein ganz schlechtes Zeichen. Es ist meistens Licht. Ja? Ja. Du weißt immer noch nicht. Nee, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung. Hä, wo war das denn? In der Innenstadt oder auf der Autobahn? Das war in der Innenstadt, beim Edeka.
Okay. Direkt da vor der Einfahrt. Wahrscheinlich hast du jemandem geschnitten. Und das waren Autofahrer auch. Ja, war Autofahrer, ja. Ja, ich habe es häufiger, dann vergesse ich das Licht anzumachen. Und das, ehrlich gesagt, das Licht im Smart, in diesen Smart, Car2Go-Smart, vergesse ich immer anzumachen, weil du hast ja so ein Standlicht, das bin ich nicht gewohnt einfach. Ich denke immer, es ist automatisch Licht an dann.
Weil du machst den Motor an und es ist automatisch Licht.
Und ich finde es sehr gefährlich, weil wenn es schon so ein automatisches Standlicht hat, dann doch bitte auch einfach mach das Abländlicht direkt an, weil ich bin es nicht gewohnt, bei meinem Auto muss ich mal Licht anmachen komplett und dann vergesse ich es ja auch nicht, weil dann sehe ich ja nichts, wenn ich fahre. Aber das ist gerade so ein automatisches Light-Licht, schwierig, Light Zero an. Und dann vergesse ich das richtige Licht anzumachen. Und dann kommen auch Leute, die mir einen Wischer machen oder die immer sagen, mach mal die Fensterscheibe runter. Und so würde ich immer sagen, nee, will ich nicht so gern. Und dann irgendwann nach der dritten Ampel r die dann einfach rüber, mach dein fucking Licht an, du Spacko. Und dann verstehe ich, ah ja. Aber das ist mir noch nie passiert, dass ich nicht wusste, worum es geht. Das finde ich immer den cool zum Moment in so Filmen oder so, wenn jemand bei Nacht so eine Verfolgungsjagd oder irgendjemand wird überfallen. Mach das Licht aus. Und fährt dann nachts und macht dann das Licht aus. Und man denkt sich mal, du bist halt einfach weg. weg. So wenn du nachts mal Auto fährst und du hast das Licht aus in so einer Landstrasse, Amerika irgendwie und du machst das Licht aus und du bist einfach weg und du kannst rechts ranfahren und da wird jeder in dir ran vorbeifahren, weil du bist einfach nicht gesehen, das ist genial. So man kann instant weg sein einfach. Als Autofahrer geht das, als Mensch nicht.
Als Mensch nicht, nee.
Nee.
Als Mensch bist du aber auch gar nicht erst richtig da im Dunkeln.
Muss man auch sagen, weil das leuchtet nicht.
Das ist natürlich ein anderer Punkt.
Kann man Menschen mit Glühwürmchen kreuzen?
Ja.
Was würde dann glühen, ist die Frage. Die Füsse?
Der Po-Pro.
Der Podex?
Der Podex, glaube ich schon, oder?
Kann man das so eins zu eins übertragen?
Weiß ich nicht. Es gibt doch so Grafiken, wo so ein Pferd und so ein Mensch daneben und genau welcher Knochen welchem entspricht oder so. Müsste man auch bei diesem Glühwürmchen genau machen, was dann was entspricht. Aber es gibt da Tiere, die leuchten im Dunkeln. Biolumineszenz. Biolumineszenz. Wo ich mich frage, kann man das irgendwie zum Menschen bringen, weil das ist doch auch cool. Aber ist das denn anstrengend oder ist es laut für das Tier oder so? Ist es so immer, wenn das Licht an ist oder fühlt es es gar nicht? Man hat so wenig Gefühl für Würmchen fliegen. Ist es nicht ein Problem bei heutigen Gesellschaft, dass wir zu wenig Gefühl für Würmchen haben? Wir zeigen zu wenig Empathie auch für Fliegen und so. Wir wissen nicht genau, ist es denn, das denke ich mir auch mal bei Vögeln, ist es denn ein Akt für die, ist es gerade eher wie Gehen oder wie Joggen? Ja, ich glaube, Fliegen ist fucking anstrengend. Nee, aber für Vögel ja nicht. Nee, ich glaube auch für Vögel. Ist es für Vögel wie Gehen oder eher wie Joggen? Die Tatsache, dass Vögel überhaupt gehen, zeigt schon, dass Fliegen anstrengend ist. Oder ist Gehen für die wie Joggen oder Rennen? Nee, Gehen ist für die wie so Hopserlauf, glaube ich, aber Fliegen ist für die wie so Sprint mit nasser Kleidung. Was fühlt sich für die normaler an? Fliegen oder gehen? Für so eine Möwe? Ja, die Möwe kann ja noch schwimmen. Das ist ein bisschen noch schwicker. Was fühlt sich für die Möwe am normalsten an? Schwimmen, fliegen oder gehen? Ja, wenn man jetzt sagen würde ... Ich würde das mal kurz in die Community geben, mal einmal als Tweet, weil das kann man ja gut abstimmen, jetzt mal kurz, weil das ist schon interessant. Also wenn du zu der Möwe sagst, komm mal her, was denkt die, dass du meinst? Meinen die, dass man schwimmt? Also angenommen, wir haben jetzt so eine Steegsituation, wo die Möwe sowohl laufen als auch schwimmen, als auch fliegen könnte. Und du rufst so, hey, hallo, heja, he da, kannst du kurz mal kommen? Und dann denkt die Möwe, ah, was passiert jetzt? Also nicht, dass du sagst, es ist Notfall, sondern einfach nur, komm mal kurz bitte, kannst du kurz mal kommen, bitte? Was macht die Möwe dann, wovon geht sie dann aus? Geht sie, wovon fliegt sie dann aus? Was fühlt sich für die Möwe am normalsten an? Normalsten an groß oder nicht? Nee, ich glaube super, dass die Möwe sind nicht. Fliegen, gehen, schwimmen. So, wir lassen das jetzt mal für die nächsten fünf Minuten laufen. Ist das jetzt die Telegram-Gruppe oder Twitter? Twitter. Okay. Und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert. Nee, finde ich gut. Was glaubst du? Lass mal tippen, wir gucken gerade nicht hin. Ich sag dann doch, ist die Frage, ja gut, jetzt wenn man eine Community wieder um alle Ecken denkt und dann wieder das abstimmt und dann Diameter wird und dann das nimmt, was man am wenigsten nimmt. Nee, ich glaube schon gehen. Ich glaube, also, ich glaube, Fliegen ist echt ein Echt. Und ich glaube, Vögel gehen auch mehr als man denkt. Aber die Flügel sind doch offensichtlich das Erkennungsmerkmal von Vögeln und auch von Möwen. Die haben doch mehr Flügel als Fuß. Ja, aber du hast ja auch Arme. Und trotzdem läufst du mit deinen Beinen. Aber ich habe mehr Beinen als Arm. Mittlerweile. Hä? Ja, darum geht es ja. Das stimmt, aber ... Aber wir haben auch mehr Flügel als Beinchen. Aber ist das denn so?
Ist das denn von der tatsächlichen Körpermasse mehr?
Oder ist das nur ganz viel Federn?
Wenn du einen Schal um hast, dann denkst du dir auch nicht,
oh, jetzt habe ich einen dicken Hals.
Du kannst ja schon differenzieren, was Körper ist und was Schal ist. Ja, das stimmt schon.
Das ist schon recht.
Will dich mal in so einer Talkshow sehen. Mein Kopf und Kragen. Horror-Vorstellung. Weil ich denke mir immer, ich habe jedes Mal, wenn jemand anfängt zu reden, die Frage meist schon wieder vergessen. Weil nicht nur sind die Fragen sehr lang, auch dazwischen reden andere Menschen. Und ich bin auch nicht mehr in der Lage, mich so lange zu konzentrieren auf Menschen und auf Gesagtes und so. Ich hätte auch achtmal schon mein Handy rausgeholt und irgendwie wäre nebenbei bei Instagram oder so gewesen. Wer klatscht denn da immer? Ja, hallo. Hey, hey, du da, setz dich mal. Wie selbstbewusst muss man eigentlich sein, um so einer Talkshow so einen Applaus anzustimmen? Ja, das ist Wahnsinn, das ist echt Wahnsinn. Nee, aber auch immer, wenn ich so Ausschnitte aus den Talkshows sehen und dann so, oh, da hat er sich aber blamiert, Cringe-Alarm. Und ich denke jedes Mal, ja, das könnte so ich sein. Also nicht irgendwie wegen, oh, wir sind so tollpart, aber ich habe einfach Mitleid mit den Leuten, weil manchmal in der Live-Situation, man redet sich um Kopf und Kragen, kommt nicht raus und manchmal sind es ja auch Leute, wo alle im Raum wollen, dass die auflaufen, die hauen sich eine gewagte These raus und dann so, ja, das habe ich ja so nicht gemeint und dann aus dem Kondex gerissen und dann indirekte Rede, direkte Rede vermischt und so, keine Chance.
Deswegen Talkshows, da habe ich grossen Respekt vor Leuten, die in Talkshows sind. Wurrst du mal eingeladen, eine krasse Talkshow?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Doch, ich wurde immer eingeladen, als es darum ging, so was darf Satire, wo ich immer denke, oh Gott, wer bin ich denn vor allem, das zu beantworten?
Ja.
Keiner, weiß ich nicht. Lade mich mal so Formel 1 oder so ein. Ja. Doppelpass. Aber da hast du jetzt angefangen. Wie ist denn in Formel 1, wie tief bist du eingetaucht? Du hast angefangen, Drive to Survive zu schauen. Ist mir die Woche eingefallen übrigens, dass jemand angefangen hat, vor dem ich nicht gedacht hätte, die Formel 1-Doku zu haben. Und mir ist das nicht eingefallen. Dir fehlt immer ein Teil in dem Kaleidoskop von so einer Geschichte. Und dann finde ich, dass du es warst. Wie cool. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist der am wenigsten, dem ich zugetraut hätte. Mega. Ich schaue da immer rein, ich schaue da beim Essen immer rein und ist auf jeden Fall toll. Ich weiß nicht, ob das nur dramaturgisch für die Serie so geschnitten ist, aber ich war überrascht, wie viele Unfälle es gibt. Ich dachte, so einen Unfall gibt es einmal im Jahr oder so, dass da einer von der Strasse abkommt. Nee, das ist schon die ganze Zeit. Aber auch nicht die ganze Zeit, aber so dreimal pro Rennen oder zweimal pro Rennen. Ich dachte, das wäre viel, viel seltener. Aber das hat mich auf jeden Fall irritiert, wie schnell die einfach draußen sind und dann einfach diese mickrigen Räder an diesen mickrigen Stängeln. Ich denke mir so, mach da doch mal so ein Schützblech drüber oder mal so richtige Bolzen ran. Immer so ein kleiner Dotz und dann rennt der Reifen schon davon. Dann fand ich es weird, dass die Teams gegeneinander spielen auch. Das ist das Tollste an Formel 1 überhaupt. Es ist genial, dass jeder Verein, jeder Rennstall, hat halt zwei Fahrer, die gegeneinander fahren, die mit dem exakt gleichen Mitteln kämpfen. Und dann gab es da diese eine Szene, wo der eine dann den anderen überholen wollte, beide vom selben Team, der ich glaube eins und zwei oder was auch immer die Position waren, und dann wollte der eine halt so ein gewagtes Überholmanöver machen, hat aber den vorderen so dumm angecrashed, dass beide raus waren. Ja, Red Bull, Max Verstappen und dann der Di Ricardo. Und man. Und man denkt, nach dem Rennen muss da auch der Trainer kommen so. So, Leute, was war das jetzt für eine Nummer? What the fuck? Also, du wolltest unbedingt Erster sein anstatt Zweiter und hast deswegen beide rausgekriegt. Ja, sorry. Und das ist schon eigentlich bescheuert, oder? Ich finde, so ein Team sollte an einem Strang ziehen. Aber gut, ich meine, es ist eine andere Dramaturgie als jetzt im Fussball oder so. Fussball. Fussball. Mit F-O-O-Z-E geschrieben. Fussball. Fussball. Aber ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Sport. Auf jeden Fall. Und natürlich auch toll, dass du diese ganzen Kameraeinstellungen hast, wo du es siehst. Beim Fussball gibt es ja noch mal eine Möglichkeit. Das gab es ja bei der Olympiade, dass die so diese Standkameras hatten, dass da in den Startböcken, Startrampen, da Kameras drin waren, fanden dann auch wieder nicht alle toll, aber glaubst du, man weil es inzwischen die Beine gefilmt hat oder so was, ja, glaubst du, diese Medienvereinnahmung geht noch weiter irgendwie so, ich sag jetzt mal, Fussballer mit einer GoPro auf dem Kopf. Schnell so Klose stürmt auf dem Fuss, auf das Tor zu. Ich bin eine Referenz auf den 2000ern. Auf die Kiste irgendwie Figo stürmt auf die Kiste zu. Zack, Schlenzer von rechts. Oh, Donkwa. Aber ehrlich gesagt, sag mir nichts. Ehrlich gesagt, clever, nur halt bei Fussball spielt der Kopf mit.
Also da mit Kopfball und so, das geht nicht.
Also das ist was für das Köpfchen auch.
Fussball ist auch was für Köpfchen.
Du kannst ja auch Tore mit dem Kopfwäsch erzielen, da ist eine GoPro dann vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber ja, dann kriegst du halt die GoPro halt so unter das Kinn, als Doppelkinn oder so an die Brust, ja Brust, Hand, womit darf man den, Hand, an die Hand, literally, ist die einzige, will ich ja in den GoPro befestigen. So wie aus Pans Labyrinth, die so in den Händen die Augen haben, so laufen Fussballern auch rum. Ja, genau. Und dann kriegt man eine gelbe Karte, wenn man die Sicht versperrt. Aber das wäre doch mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, letzte Minute, Ball im Netz und dann hast du noch mal das Bild von Ich finde es ganz toll, diese Spider-Cam, die es im Stadion gibt, die an vier Fixpunkten befestigt sind oben und im Prinzip durch Seile halt überall hin können. Aber werfen da Leute nicht Sachen drauf? Ja, ja, und da sind auch häufig dann Fahnen dran und sowas. Da werfen Leute Sachen drauf, ja. Ist auch nicht zu ver... Also Leute werfen Dinge auf Dinge. Die Zerstörungswut des Menschen kennt keine Grenzen. Nee, Spaßwut, aber auch eine grosse Spaßwut. So, und zwar haben wir jetzt ein Ergebnis. Und es ist sehr eindeutig. Wir haben einmal 18%, einmal 22%, einmal 60%. Also Fliegen, Gehen, Schwimmen. Auf Platz drei, sagst du, ist was mit 18% gehen. Was? Mit 18% gehen. Dann 22% schwimmen. Auf Platz eins mit 60% fliegen. Ja gut, die haben keine Ahnung. Unsere Community ist natürlich fantastisch und hat uns auch diese Woche wieder tolle Dinge zukommen lassen, denn letzte Folge haben wir angekündigt, wir wollen mal so ein Abenteuer erleben, wir wollen mal richtig was haben, was man dann irgendwie am Esstisch mit Freunden erzählen kann, wo man dann so ein bisschen hinleitet, so die Hälfte des Gesprächs, so ja, ja, wie damals in Namibia, dann fragt die mal nach und dann kommt nochmal zweiter Gang und dann nochmal Eis und dann ist der Abend vorbei, man muss ihn nochmal einladen, das ist dann halt das Zwiebeln. Ja, und dann so, ja, in Namibia gab es überhaupt kein Eis, ne?
Ach, du warst in Namibia. Ja!
Ja, erzähl doch mal, wie es in Namibia war.
Und wir wollen so eine Geschichte haben, die man so auf zwei, drei Nachstochen dann erzählt und dann denken wir, oh, die war doch ganz gut.
Wir haben ein paar Vorschläge bekommen, auf welche Abenteuer wir uns denn begeben könnten.
Welche Schatzjagd.
Wir wollen eine Schatzjagd und wir haben gesagt, wir wollen auch was Knackiges. Also was man in so einem halben Wochenende irgendwie, man kommt ein bisschen zu spät, Check-in, erstmal eine Stunde auch auf dem Hotel, jeder für sich und dann... Erstmal ankommen. Erstmal ankommen, erstmal Minibar. Genau. Erstmal Fernsehen, erstmal Vox, erstmal die Zahlen der Fernsehsender aufschreiben, erstmal Vox suchen. Eur Eurosport, erst mal Altersierer suchen, was gibst du alles?
Altersierer oft auf eins oder zwei in Hotels.
Genau, das mal kurz durchklicken irgendwie und dann mal irgendwie so gegen Abend mal anfangen zu lesen. Wir haben drei Vorschläge bekommen für Abenteuer und ich überlasse jetzt dir, du gibst mir ein bis zehn Bigfoot-Spuren, wie realistisch du es empfindest, dass wir dieses Rätsel lösen. Lösen, okay. Lösen, ja. Also einfach, weil ich glaube, wir wollen eine sichere Bank, oder? Also ich glaube, wir sind uns beide einig. Wir wollen eine sichere Bank, wir wollen da hin und dann auch mit einem Vorten. Es muss ein Win sein. Es muss ein Win sein. Also im Idealfall durchgeplant bis zum Ende, auch mit jemandem, der uns dann da hinführt, auch mal zurück irgendwie was trägt, wenn es zu schwer wird und so, der auch so das Notfallpack in der Tasche hat, falls du mal einen Skorpion anfasst, den man nicht kennt oder direkt weiss, so einen dabei haben, der uns dann auch im Idealfall so leitet, dass wir da ankommen, in der er schon mal da war, aber jetzt noch nicht das Ressel gelöst hat. Genau, aber kurz davor ist.
Und nur noch so die Puzzlestücke müssen reingelegt werden. Also, die erste Nachricht kam zum Unglück am Dyatlov-Pass. Klingt immer mega. Und das war der mysteriöse Tod von neun Bergsteigern 1959.
Und zwar auf dem Dyatlov-Pass in der ehemaligen Sowjetunion sind neun erfahrene Bergsteiger gestorben, erfroren. Aber und scheiß, ich weiß doch jetzt schon, in welche Richtung es geht. Neun erfahrene Bergsteiger sterben in einem Ausflug. Ja, wir sind zwei nicht erfahrene Bergsteiger und müssten ja jetzt mal irgendwie nach Adam Riese den gleichen Weg gehen. Genau, um nachzugucken, was da vor einundsechzig Jahren passiert ist. Die sind gestorben, und zwar sind die anscheinend nachts eingeschlafen und sind dann unter mysteriösen Umständen haben sie ihr Zelt verlassen. Und zwar hatten die teilweise gar nicht genug Kleidung an, manche hatten nur einen Schuh an. Und man weiß nicht genau, warum die das Zelt verlassen haben, ohne sich darauf vorzubereiten, mit der Kälte, Nachtkälte klarzukommen, obwohl das warne Bergsteige wären. Und die sind gestorben, und tatsächlich bei der Obduktion wurde eine erhöhte Radioaktivität gemessen. Also man weiß nicht genau, was da passiert ist. War es ein geheimer militärischer Test, waren zu UFOs, niemand weiß es. Lest euch gerne durch die ganze Geschichte auf Wikipedia. Also das war ein Vorschlag, dass wir in diesem 61 Jahre alten Fall nochmal auf die Spur gehen. Okay, ja, ungeklärter Fall. Anscheinend ist und sehr, aber auch sehr gross. Also da werden ja schon Leute ermittelt haben, gehe ich immer davon aus. Wahrscheinlich haben da Leute... Ich sehe uns, ehrlich gesagt, bin ich ganz ehrlich nicht auf dem Diablo-Pas rumschlendern mit unseren Turntürchen. Ich habe ein Paar Schuhe, diese Reeboks, die werde ich auch da anhaben, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Und die dürfen auch nicht so dreckig werden eigentlich. Ich könnte vorher in Globetrotter gehen hier, werde es verchecken, ich werde diese To-Do-Nachricht in meinem Eikalender nicht gelesen haben. Ich gebe uns einen von fünf Bigfoot-Spuren. Alles klar, okay, also abgeschmettert würde ich sagen an der Stelle. Abgeschmettert, ja. Also Diatiatlov Pass müssen wir leider zurückstecken, vielleicht nächstes Jahr.
Mal gucken, wo es ihr in uns treibt, falls ihr erfahrene Bergsteiger seid.
Dann hat uns Lea geschrieben.
Und zwar verspricht uns Lea einen Ort, der alles hat.
Schatzsuche, Abenteuer, Bösewichte, Nervenkitzel.
Folgendes.
Bösewichte?
Lea schreibt, es geht um das Haus meiner Grossmutter, die leider schon verstorben ist. Da klang erst mal wie noch Heidepark, Heidepark Werbung. Bösewichte, Schurken, Abenteuer. Genau, Lea Marketing, Heidepark. Sehr gut, cleverste Werbung. Und zwar das Haus ihrer Grossmutter, die leider schon verstorben ist. Das Haus selber ist über 300 Jahre alt und an sich schon wahnsinnig interessant. Bevor die Familie meiner Oma in Besitz dieses Hauses kam, wohnte dort ein Goldschmied. Meine Oma meinte immer, es sei ein böser und geiziger Mensch gewesen. Dieser Goldschmied war sehr wohlhabend, aber nach seinem Tod wurde nichts von seinen Wertsachen gefunden. Man munkelt, er hätte es in den Wänden eingemauert oder vergraben. Meine Grossmutter, meine Eltern und natürlich viele Kinder haben immer wieder nach diesem Schatz gesucht, sogar mit Metalldetektoren, aber wir sind nie fündig geworden. Es wäre an der Zeit, dieses Mysterium ein für alle Mal aufzuklären. Es geht noch weiter. Wo ist das Haus? Weiß ich nicht ganz genau. Ich glaube, das will sie natürlich nicht sagen, weil sonst würden da jetzt die ganzenut nachzusehen. Das Haus liegt in Süddeutschland. Die Dachböden sind sehr hoch, Griechen ist also nicht erforderlich. Sehr gut, sehr gut, solltet ihr Interesse haben, meldet euch. Also, wir können nicht nur einen Schatz finden von einem ehemaligen bösen, geizigen Goldschmied, was eine klassische Dagobert Duck Story ist, sondern auch Waffen und Bomben aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Das war der einzige Abturner, wo ich sage, da sehe ich meine Gedärme durch den sehr hohen, komfortablen, begehbaren Attic. Da müssen wir auch sagen, Lea, extrem vernünftig, nicht dorthin zu gehen, wo deine Oma gesagt hat, dass dort Waffen und Bomben, ich weiß nicht genau, welche deutschen Kriegsflüchtlinge das sein sollen, die Bomben dabei haben.
Also entweder das so gegen Ende des Krieges oder sie meint mit Bomben halt eher sowas wie Handgranaten oder so, aber keine Ahnung, man weiß es nicht genau. Wow, das ist ein, also das kriegt ganze fünf von fünf, fünf von ganze fünf von fünf Loch Ness-Fotos, weil ehrlich gesagt, ich habe das Gefühl, das kriegt man hin. Wir denken ja auch so ein bisschen out of the box, wir denken zwischen den Wänden, ich fühle mich da zu Hause. Ich habe da total Spaß dran, da mal vorbeizufahren. Vor allem, ich meine, wir haben ja über Fluchtwörter gesprochen. Ich finde, ein klassisches Fluchtwort ist auch munkeln. Denn sie schreibt, man munkelt, das Gold ist in den Wänden oder vergraben. Und das ist auch so, woher kommt diese Munkelei? Also da ist jemand gestorben, der hatte Geld, und dann hat man keine Reichtümer gefunden. Also munkelt man, der hat sie vergraben. Das ist ja ein relativ dünner Hinweis, also vielleicht der ist auch vererbt oder so, woanders man weiß, also das müssen wir halt alles aufklären. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, also das Wort Stadtarchiv ist nicht gefallen, wo ich immer sofort denke, geil, weil da kann man jetzt noch ein bisschen recherchieren, zum einen, wer weiß noch was über den, hat er ja Freunde. Ja genau, warum war der so gemein? Also da sehe ich schon den großen Podcast-Ufo-Dreiteiler.
Ja.
Ehrlich gesagt, komm. Das Rätsel von, wir wissen noch nicht, wie die Stadt heisst.
Warum war der so böse, der Goldschmied? Sind Goldschmiede nicht eigentlich sehr froh?
Geiziger Goldschmied bin ich auch eine mega Story.
Ja, ja, ja. Da machen wir so ein eigenes Serial daraus. Und du gibst fünf von fünf?
Ich gebe fünf von fünf Fotos von noch Ness.
Also, leer, absoluter Jackpot hier. Wir melden uns, aber vielleicht kann dich Geschichte drei noch überzeugen, denn Tobias schreibt uns und zwar der mysteriöse Wedding-Knall. In Wedding? Und zwar schreibt uns Tobias, dass es in Berlin Wedding in 2014 mehrfach laut geknallt hat und niemand weiss, warum. Am 31.12. Wann? Und zwar 2014 knallte es mehrfach zwischen... Tobi ist einfach sauer auf seinen Nachbarn. Auch albern jetzt. Es knallte mehrfach zwischen dreiundzw Uhr in Berlin-Wedding und hat sogar einmal einen Grosseinsatz der Feuerwehr ausgelöst, aber niemand weiß warum. Niemand weiß was, es hat anscheinend mehrfach geknallt, in mehreren Nächten, immer zwischen 23 und 1 Uhr und niemand weiß was da los ist, sind es irgendwelche geheimen Meth-Labore oder Waffentests, alte Bomben in Berlin? Aliens? Niemand weiß es, Aliens? Das gibt von mir drei von fünf UFOs. Drei von fünf UFOs. Weil ich sage, ehrlich gesagt, lösbar wahrscheinlich schon. Ja. Ich sehe uns aber am Ende nicht mit Tütenweiser Gold den Beding-Wedding verlassen. Von daher hält sich meine Motivation so ein bisschen in Grenzen. Es hat ja auch nur geknallt. Also es ist niemand verschwunden. Aber es hat richtig geknallt. Es können auch mal alle, ja wie laut, hat es gedonnert oder hat es geknallt? Ja, damit es eine Feuerwehreinsatz auslöst, muss ich schon ordentlich rumpsen. Rumpsen, hat es gerumpst? Nee, es hat geknallt. Geknallt. Das ist schon das lauteste Wort. Also es gibt einen, ich habe einen Spiegelartikel gibt es dazu, den könnt ihr euch gerne durchlesen, wenn ihr den findet, aber ich glaube vor allem 2014. Wie liest er? Laute Knalle in Wedding. Knall von Wedding, was wurde aus dem rätselhaften Geräusch? Das ist der Spiegelartikel? Das ist der Spiegelartikel. Schon geil, ehrlich gesagt.
Also 2014 ist halt
so eine Zeit, das ist jetzt sechs Jahre her.
Da hat es schon mal geknallt.
Aber da findet man auf jeden Fall Ohrenzeugen.
Und man
findet vielleicht auch, vor allem
falls ich ein Geräusch von diesem
Knall, falls es jemand aufgenommen hat, weil wenn es mehrmals
knallt, muss ja bestimmt jemand auf die Idee gekommen sein,
da man Aufnahmegeld aufdenkt. War es ein unregelmäßiges Intervall? Das weiß ich, ich habe den Artikel nicht gelesen, ich habe nur die Überschrift gelesen. Okay, also du liest dann die Mails und kopierst ja auch in dein lustiges Textformat-Ding da, aber du bist nicht bereit, die diesen extra Mails zu gehen, den Artikel zu lesen. Nee, mehr mache ich nicht. Und ich sag mal so, sollte ich ein Geräusch von diesem Knall gefunden haben, dann hört ihr das jetzt.
So, also vielleicht habe ich was gefunden oder nicht. Warst du in Berlin zu dem Zeitpunkt? 2014? Da warst du doch da. Ja, stimmt. Da warst du doch in Berlin, aber nicht in Berlin. Ja, stimmt, 2014 war ich nicht in Wedding, nee, ich war in Mitte. Interessant, das finde ich ja super spannend. Also, aber wie gesagt, da löst man halt was. Jetzt finde ich es ein bisschen spannender schon, ich erhöhe auf vier von fünf Ufos, weil man ja jetzt zumindest einen Spiegelartikel lösen könnte. Genau. Also das finde ich ja schon spannend, wenn es halt wirklich im Interesse, ich dachte, das war ja so ein bisschen so eine Fehle mit seinem Nachbarn oder sowas, also denkbar, weil das jetzt wirklich so in der Public Meinung war. Und man hat einen Ansprechpartner, man kann mit dem Journalisten sprechen. Vielleicht wurde es mittlerweile auch schon aufgeklärt, also falls Berliner zuhören und ihr da mehr Informationen haben, falls ihr diesen Kanal vielleicht sogar selber gehört habt, dann schreibt uns, vielleicht können wir es, idealerweise würden wir dieses Rätsel lösen, ohne diese Studios zu verlassen. Nein, da haben wir andere, das sagst du jetzt so, speak for yourself. Du willst schon einmal kurz raus, du bist die Beine vertreten. Ja, wie gesagt, jetzt mit so einem guten Hotel und so. Ich will jetzt auch nicht, ich will auch im Wochenende noch mal abschalten, so bin ich ja ganz ehrlich, nach so einer harten Woche. Abenteuer ja, aber in Maßen. Also du würdest sagen, Süddeutschland zu Lea, da bist du dabei. Ein schönes so für Jahreszeiten. Bin ich dabei. Und wenn in Berlin Wedding, dann auch Berlin Wedding. Also dann können wir da hin. Wir können auch beides machen, finde ich beides interessant. Ich würde gerne erstmal zu Lea, Süddeutschland, und dann dem gierigen Goldschmied auf den Zahn fühlen, auf den Goldzahn fühlen. Dann machen wir uns ein schönes Bergsteigen, ein bisschen bayerische Vanillecreme, dann machen wir uns ein schönes Wochenende. Machen wir uns ein schönes bayerisches Wochenende, fände ich total schön. Ja. Ich brauche jetzt nicht in dem Haus wohnen, 300 Jahre alt klingt nach, ehrlich gesagt, klingt unkomfortabel, finde ich jetzt ehrlich. Ja. Also vielleicht, nee, finde ich schon schön. 300 Jahre altes Haus, das einen Dachboden hat, in dem man stehen kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob du drin stehen kannst, das hat eher nicht spezifiziert. Vor 300 Jahren waren die Menschen ja riesig. Das war ein RiesenursOurs. Deswegen haben die auch so große Häuser gebraucht. Der Kölner Dom, da haben so drei, vier Leute reingepasst. Nee, die waren groß. Das waren zwei Brüder, die in den Türmen gewohnt haben, links und rechts. Die konnten da mit der Hand wie so ein Dschengerturm oben die Sachen noch drauf tun. Ganz locker. Also das waren die Abenteuer, das ist alles, was wir eingeschickt bekommen haben. Also erstmal vielen Dank für alle Einsendungen. Vielen Dank für das Vertrauen, für das Respekt, dass wir diesen Dyatlov-Passfall lösen könnten.
Also vielen Dank.
Auch da vielen Dank.
Aber ich glaube, das ist eine Nummer zu groß einfach.
Sowjetische Nuklearexperimente sind glaube ich eine Nummer. Folge drei.
Genau.
Das ist ein bisschen zu groß.
Ich habe auch keine Lust, dass irgendwann dieser Podcast irgendwie so eine Spielwiese für Geheimdienste ist oder so. Nee, da hätte ich gar keinen Bock drauf. Wo die dann so die auszubildenden Geheimdienste dann Podcast-Ufo hören, schicken, weil wir dann doch low-key beobachtet werden, habe ich auch nicht so Bock drauf. Vor allem, als wir diesen Podcast angefangen haben, dachten natürlich alle Leute, ach, ihr macht das über UFO oder was und so. Wir so, nee, nee, nee, nur Quatsch. So, aber glaubst du, wir werden irgendwann... Die Ersten Ersten, die es herausfinden, dass UFOs gibt. Entweder das, oder wir werden wirklich langsam so in Verschwörungstheorien und Mystery-Podcast. Du, ich bin da auch offen und anfällig für, ehrlich gesagt. Du hast ja immer gesagt, Nomen est Omen, und man wird zu dem, was man heißt. Sag mir, wer du... Ich sag aber auch... Wie du heisst und ich sag dir, wer du bist, ist ja das alte Sprichwort. Kommen wir bei Your Name. Ich sage aber auch Homo homony lupus est.
Ich sage vieles.
Ich sage vieles, was ich noch weiss.
Seit du dein Latino abgeschlossen hast durch die Ferne Uni Aachen, hast du eine Menge zu sagen, mein Lieber.
Eine ganze Menge zu sagen.
Ich habe eine Menge lateinische Sachen zu sagen.
Richtig viel zu sagen.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Aber dieser Podcast fliegt natürlich nicht nur in halsbrächerische Höhen, sondern wir werfen den Blick natürlich auch in den Süden, über den Horizont. Und was finden wir da? Unser Lieblingskontinent Afrika!
Afrika! Hier ist Antenne Afrika, das ist unsere fantastische Rubrik, in dem wir diesen geheimnisvollen, riesigen, riesigen Kontinent Afrika erkunden. Und zwar, Afrika ist ja nicht nur ein Name, sondern 55 Stück, 55 Länder, die dieser Kontinent in sich ruhen hat. Und wir schauen uns alle davon an, wir haben schon einige angeschaut, du guckst mich schon, du guckst mich an, wie wirklich bei der Lateinabfrage, wo gleich aufgerufen wird. Ich habe die ganze Woche schon Angst davor, dass wir dieses Kofferparkspiel machen. Ich freue mich aber wahnsinnig, dass wir jetzt ein Land haben, über das ich denkbar wenig weiß.
Was wir meinlich aber auch schon mal aufgezählt hatten,
als ein Land, was mir schon mal...
Ja, wir waren so ein bisschen...
Wo ist nur ein Fehler unterlaufen.
Ja, wir waren so ein bisschen im Ori-Dori-Oin-Gloin-Modus
und haben Uganda direkt Ruanda hinterher geschoben.
Gibt es tatsächlich auch in Afrika, aber von...
Ja, Fun Fact, wenn man einen Buchstaben ändert,
gibt es das Land dann meistens noch in Afrika.
Weil man hat das... Es ist nicht wie Südamerika, wo man einfach durchdreht mit Ecuador, Peru, Argentinien, Brasilien, das ist einfach, das ist dann doch da noch ein bisschen einfacher, die Namensfindung ist ein bisschen einfacher. Genau, unter anderem zum Beispiel in Ruanda, wie gesagt, und da haben wir eine fantastische Korrespondentin, die uns einen Beitrag geschickt hat, und zwar Sophie schickt uns einen Beitrag über Ruanda. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, denn ich muss ganz ehrlich zugeben, über Ruanda, mein Wissen über Ruanda passt auf den Diener, schön auf den Diener 5. Passt in die Landesgrenze von Ruanda, wenn es ein kleines, wenn es ein kleines, wenn es ein kleines, kann auch groß sein. Und das soll sich ändern mit Sophie, bitteschön. Hallo ihr Lieben, ich wollte auch mal was zu dem Thema Afrika hinzufügen, weil mir das sehr wichtig ist und ich freue mich auch, dass ihr das angesprochen habt und deswegen dachte ich, füge ich jetzt auch mal was hinzu. Ruanda wird eigentlich in Afrika immer so die Schweiz Afrikas genannt, weil es ein super kleines Land ist, das oftmals unterschätzt wird. Es ist sehr, sehr grün und es wird auch das Land der Tausendhügel genannt. Die Hauptstadt ist Kigali, da habe ich ein Jahr lang gewohnt, und die Sprache ist Kinjawanda und mittlerweile auch Englisch. Als ich damals in Ruanda angekommen bin, am Flughafen, hat mich eine Sache total überrascht, und zwar wurde ich nicht nur nach Waffen abgecheckt, sondern auch nach Plastik. Und das war ich irgendwie überhaupt nicht gewohnt und habe ich überhaupt nicht erwartet. Ruanda ist nämlich ein komplett plastikfreies Land. Ähm, also selbst wenn man Brot in einer Plastiktüte mitbringt, holen die das raus, das Brot, und machen das in eine Papiertüte rein. Was mich in Ruanda auch sehr überrascht hat, ist das Klima. Viele denken ja, oh, Afrika ist superheiss. In Ruanda wird es nie heißer als 25 Grad. Die Sommer in Deutschland sind teilweise echt viel, viel heißer als in Ruanda. Ich habe mir manchmal gewünscht, wieder zurückzugehen.
Eine andere Sache, die mich auch total inspiriert hat, war, dass jeden Sonntag in Ruanda, also in ganz Ruanda, der Aufräumtag ist.
Der wird Umuganda genannt, das ist Kinjawanda, und da kommen alle Hausgemeinschaften zusammen, um ihren Bereich, ihre Umgebung aufzuräumen, gemeinsam.
Was für mich immer super einfach war, ist der Transport in Ruanda. Also meistens nimmt man sich einfach ein Taxi, und zwar ein Mototaxi. Die gibt es nämlich überall in Ruanda. Das sind einfach kleine Motorräder, die überall rumfahren und die du mit einem Handwinken aufhältst und auf die du dich dann hinten draufsetzt und für 20, 30 Cent zum nächsten Ort fahren. Und die waren echt immer super praktisch. Natürlich hat auch jeder einen Helm dabei für dich, weil in Ruanda ist ja auch Helmpflicht. Und ich als Frau finde das natürlich super, dass Ruanda einen Frauenanteil im Parlament hat von über 60 Prozent%, was der meiste Frauenanteil in dem Parlament
weltweit ist. Und wenn ihr zum Schluss noch mal kurz hören wollt, wie sich Kinyawanda
eigentlich anhört, mir fallen jetzt so spontan noch ein paar Wörter ein, wie zum Beispiel
Wie geht's dir? Heißt Amakuru, mir geht's gut? Heißt Mimesa oder Guten Morgen, heißt zum Beispiel Baramutze. Ja, so, das war mein kleiner Exkurs durch Ruanda. Ich hoffe, er hat euch ein bisschen weitergeholfen. Vielleicht habt ihr ja mal Lust, eine Reise nach Ruanda zu starten. Lohnt sich auf jeden Fall. Tschüss. Ey, dann ein herzliches Mimwanda nach Ruanda an, Sophie, vielen Dank. Ja, man erkennt ein Muster, offensichtlich. Es klingt alles sehr ähnlich, aber ich finde es gut, ein Land, das sich reimt. Vielleicht ist dir das gar nicht so aufgefallen, aber es klingt alles sehr ähnlich. Sehr, sehr interessant, Ruanda, ein tolles Land. Ist es so ein bisschen vielleicht auch des Kanada-Afrikas? Nee, die Schweiz-Afrikas. Bei Kanada ist doch immer so das Vorzeige. Was Kanada für die USA ist, ist Ruanda für Afrika. Okay. So ein bisschen so, ah, die machen alles besser, die haben ein besseres Gesundheitssystem und so in Ruanda, oh, die sind alles perfekt. Mega, dass die Frauenunternehmen fand ich ganz toll. Ich fand auch ein Plastikfreies Land natürlich auch mega. Wie cool. Supergut. Also das hat mir schon sehr gut gefallen, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, auf jeden Fall, klingt gut und natürlich auch, vielleicht wäre es ganz gut, wenn wir uns informieren, wo das liegt in Afrika, oder damit man so eine grobe Ahnung hat. Lass mich mal ganz kurz nachgucken, du hast schon recht, ich wüsste jetzt auch gar nicht genau, wo das liegt. Weil wir versuchen euch darauf vorzubereiten, dass falls ihr mal in einer Quizshow irgendwie im Fernsehen seid oder so, dass ihr dann sagen könnt, ah, auf der Karte kann ich Rwanda erkennen und woher weißt du das denn, vom Podcast-Ufo und so, kriegen wir neue Hörer. Rwanda ist wirklich ganz, ganz klein, liegt ganz in der Mitte von Afrika. Ja. Und nahe, nähe des Viktoriasees, den man ja vielleicht noch kennt, bei Kenia, bei Tansania, da die Ecke, Demokratische Republik Kongo. Genau, also sehr in der Mitte, Zentralafrika, sieht wirklich fantastisch aus, oh mein Gott, da kann man wirklich ganz tolle Bilder sehen. Ich bin eh großer Fan davon, afrikanische Länder zu googeln und dann die Bilder anzugucken, weil die immer anders sind, das ist wirklich fantastisch. Vielen, vielen Dank an Sophie und wir haben ein neues Land dazugelernt, Rwanda, und natürlich versuchen wir uns immer alles einzuprägen,
mit euch natürlich, egal wo ihr seid, ihr müsst mitsprechen. Wir lernen die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia und Uganda. Richtig, ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia, Uganda und Tansania. Ich lehre die Länder Afrikas, Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien.
Ja, genau richtig. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien und Sambia.
Namibia, Uganda, Tansania,
Äthiopien, Sambia
und Ruanda. Genau.
Richtig. Das ist alles
nicht mehr so einfach und es wird
jetzt schon unmöglich und ich freue mich
schon auf Land. 55 Stück.
Das war an der Welt. Aber wie cool, dass ihr
auf der ganzen Welt verteilt seid. Das wollte ich immer sagen. Ganz, ganz toll.
Das war die Länder Afrikas. Ja, volle Sendung heute. Wir haben viel erlebt, wir haben viel erfahren, wir haben viel gelernt. Ja, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du uns auf diese kleine Reise begleitet hast. Sehr gerne, vielen Dank auch an dich, Laurentin Will, dass du auch alles immer so toll vorbereitet und auch die Artikel liest und dich einfach ganz, ganz blenden. Unironisch, danke für das Sichten der ganzen Mails, die du für uns... Gerne, vielen, vielen Dank an alle, die Konstruktives eingesendet haben und haut rein, macht's noch schön. Oh, ein Augen, ein kleiner, eine satirische Spitze hinten raus.
Ja, und nicht an diesen einen Witzball, der uns immer ein Intro schickt.
Und es ist immer Toxic von von Britney Spears.
Und er schreibt immer unter einem anderen Namen.
Und es geht mir auf die Nerven.
Macht's gut, haut rein, schön Wochen noch.
Macht's gut, schöne Woche, ciao, ciao.
Macht's gut, ciao.